one of the things that I've been saying
here when it comes to the whole idea of
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars is
that this is basically going to be
Avengers forever right it'll be done by
a different name and it may include
elements of battle world but it's going
to be Avengers forever this is going to
be a series of films that are basically
going to focus on bringing together an
Avengers team a multiversal Avengers
team that includes members who have been
plucked from the time stream so
literally what Marvel could do is say
okay Captain America is going into the
past he's going to put the Infinity
Stones back to where they're supposed to
be but then he's recruited by Loki
Loki's like hey Cat we got a great big
huge problem came the conquerors back
he's trying to destroy the whole
Multiverse we need your help we're
forming a multiversal Avengers team and
let's say that he's met by like Robert
Downey Jr's Iron Man maybe like right
when he first became Iron Man as opposed
to when he died during the events of
Avengers end